Ich möchte nur ein paar Worte über den Impakt dieses effizienten neurologischen Breakthroughs beenden.
In anderen Worten, die unorthodoxen Tendenzen gegen ihr eigenes Leben, die sich immer auf die natürliche Erdung des Familienunits verletzt, werden nicht mehr den biologischen Unterstützung des Organismus haben.
Die Erkennung des ArtSem, die mit der Neutralisierung des Orgasms verbunden wird, wird die Familie effektiv auslösen, bis sie nicht mehr konzeptualisiert werden kann.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 81. Und ja, nachdem es jetzt so ein paar sehr technische Sendungen gab, achso, erst mal vorstellen, hallo, Tim Pritlove am Mikrofon und ich sag auch gleich noch das Datum, es ist der 17.03.08 und der Kopf dreht sich mir schon, weil wir hier so viel vorbesprochen haben über den innerhalb dieser besonderen Sendung und ich verrate auch gleich mal, wer der Gast ist, es ist nämlich Maha. Hallo Maha, ich muss vielleicht dein Mikrofon noch mal einschalten, probieren wir es noch mal. Das war nämlich auch Teil hier der Vorbereitung, alles noch mal umstellen auf ein ganz anderes Recording-Setup, das hat mir jetzt doch einige Aufmerksamkeit abgerungen und man merkt, dass es nicht spurlos an mir vorbeigegangen. Wie auch immer, jetzt sind wir ganz wach und wir wollen über etwas reden, was wir jetzt hier in diesem kleinen Jingle vorab schon ein wenig gehört haben. Das war ein Ausschnitt aus 1984, ich mache ja mal ein großes Geheimnis über unsere kleinen Clips vor Chaosradio Express, aber diesmal muss es offen ausgesprochen werden. Der Film 1984 ist dort zitiert worden, mit seiner doch merkwürdigen Sprache. Also der Film 1984 basiert natürlich auf dem Buch 1984, das 1984, George Orwell. Und ja, an der Sprache konnte man schon mal ein paar Merkwürdigkeiten feststellen, vor allem ein paar merkwürdige Abkürzungen. Der Orgasmus muss ausgerottet werden und überhaupt die Familie muss komplett umgestellt werden, weil das ist alles böse, oder?
Genau, ja, das ist das, was 1984 thematisiert ist. Und das Ausrotten von diesen Dingen geht eben auch Hand in Hand mit dem Ausrotten von Konzepten und letztlich dann eben auch, indem man die Sprache verändert. Und ja, das könnte man auch mal wieder auf die aktuelle Situation beziehen. Und von daher ist es glaube ich sehr interessant, was man mit Sprache alles machen kann, um eben dann auch Einfluss auf die Wirklichkeit zu haben durch Sprache.
Neusprech. Neusprech, so heißt diese neue Sprache, die da geboren wird in dem Buch, in diesem virtuellen Staat, der dort beschrieben wird, der Big Brother, der alles überwacht. Vorhin schon mal gerätselt, wer denn dieses Buch eigentlich wirklich noch liest heutzutage oder diesen Begriff 1984 einfach nur noch symbolhaft durch die Gegend wirft. Also wer von euch das jetzt noch nicht gelesen hat, dem sei das durchaus mal angeraten oder zumindest mal in den Film reinzuschauen.
Genau, es gibt ja immer noch den Film. Es ist allerdings wirklich so, dass das heute in aller Munde geführt wird, also die Jahreszahl 1984, aber dass wenige Leute überhaupt noch wissen, worum es da eigentlich geht. Und das ist natürlich auch schwierig, weil man natürlich auch sehen muss, das steht in einem bestimmten Kontext. Das Buch ist ja 1948 geschrieben worden und es geht tatsächlich um den englischen Sozialismus, Inc. Sock, der ja da auch in dem Zitat vorkam. Und das ist natürlich auch schwierig zu übertragen auf die heutige Situation. Aber das Buch hat trotzdem an Aktualität ja eigentlich nicht verloren.
50 Jahre Orwell haben wir jetzt. Ja, genau.
Das sind tatsächlich genau 50 Jahre. Wir machen sozusagen die Jubiläums-Sendung.
Genau, die Jubiläums-Sendung zum großen Bruder. Ja, vielleicht für die, die dich noch nicht kennen, sei noch mal darauf hingewiesen. Wir haben schon ein paar Podcasts zusammen gemacht. Du stehst ja hier dem CCC auch sehr nah. Du bist ja hier im CCC Berlin auch mit organisiert, bist aber eigentlich in deinem richtigen Leben Professor für Romanistik, Sprachen, Linguist bist du halt. Wir hatten ja diesen ausführlichen Podcast zum Thema Sprachen mal gemacht, den ich jedem nur empfehlen kann, als Einstieg in dieses interessante Thema.
Richtig, wir bauen ja darauf auf.
Genau, wir bauen auch darauf auf. Das heißt, ihr müsst jetzt auf stopp drücken, den anderen Podcast runterladen.
Genau, also erstmal Chaosradio 41 hören und dann 41 war das. Radio 43 und dann können wir weitermachen mit Chaosradio 81.
43 war dein anderes Hobby, das war die Wikipedia. Da wollten wir auch irgendwann nochmal was nachlegen, aber das steht jetzt gerade nicht so an. Ja, so und das heißt, in deiner Eigenschaft als Sprachforscher hast du dir sozusagen dieses Phänomen, dieses Neusprechphänomen nochmal genau angeschaut und wir wollen heute eigentlich ein bisschen die Aufmerksamkeit auf die Gegenwart lenken und schauen, inwiefern diese Orwellchen-Konzepte heutzutage Anwendung finden.
Ja, also man muss natürlich sagen, dass Orwell natürlich eine ganz bestimmte Situation da im Auge hat, aber die gleichen Dinge kehren ja auch wieder durchaus auch in so was wie Public Relations oder so. Überhaupt jemand, der was verkaufen will, macht sich natürlich auch Gedanken darüber, wie kann man das verkaufen, auch über die Sprache und da Politik heute auch einen gewissen wahren Charakter angenommen hat, machen sich natürlich auch Politiker Gedanken darüber, wie sie ihre Konzepte verkaufen, insbesondere unpopuläre Dinge verkaufen. Und da wird natürlich in die Sprache auch eingegriffen und deshalb kann man da durchaus auch von Neussprech sprechen, obwohl natürlich jetzt hier nicht irgendwie ein totalitäres System droht. Aber dennoch gibt es solche Konzepte, die eben wahrscheinlich vor allen Dingen aus der Werbung kommen. Ich denke, das ist aber auch ganz wichtig, wenn man selber politisch aktiv werden will, denn wenn man selber gewisse Dinge durchsetzen will, braucht man auch griffige Begriffe. Und das ist auch ganz wichtig, das sehen wir ja auch, wenn wir jetzt da so ein bisschen an den Chaos- Computer Club denken und an die verschiedenen Aktivitäten. Da ist ja nun auch der Begriff Bundestrojaner geprägt worden. Und ich glaube, das war ganz wichtig, weil man jetzt plötzlich auch etwas verbildlichen konnte. Da konnte man sich so ein Pferd vorstellen und das wurde ja dann auch gebastelt. Und damit war die Sache auch begreifbar. Also Begriff, begreifbar, das hängt ja doch zusammen. Und damit kann man dann natürlich auch tatsächlich Politik machen, egal von welcher Seite man kommt.
Aber bleiben wir doch noch mal kurz beim Buch, bei dem Orwellischen Buch 1984. Was genau ist denn Neusprech? Also welche Rolle, also wie drückt es sich aus dort und vor allem was sagst du da als Linguist dazu? Finde ich ja mal ganz interessant. Und was ist das Wesen von Neusprech?
Also das Wesen von Neusprech ist, dass es sich einmal um eine vereinfachte Sprache handelt, bei der bestimmte Konzepte ja nicht da sind oder auch ja nicht so benannt werden, also oder in einer gewissen Weise benannt werden. Und eben auch in der Sprachstruktur gibt es gewisse Vereinfachungen. Es gibt also so Zusammensetzungen, die etwas anders sind, als wir aus dem heutigen, also aus dem Altsprech gewöhnt sind. Also es gibt ein Konzept. Ja, das heißt glaube ich auch genauso bei Orwell. Also z.B. Crime Think ist ein Neusprechwort. Ja, man sieht also Konzepte werden so aneinander.
Crime Think, also man heißt Thoughtcrime. Ja, Thoughtcrime ist, das war ja auch am Anfang.
Ja, Thoughtcrime ist aber jetzt Altsprech. Und Crime Think ist Neusprech.
Ach so, okay, ist Neusprech. Aber da hatte er ja vorhin Altsprech benutzt.
Genau, ja. Das ist ein bisschen, wir bekommen, gerade in dem Film, in dem Buch ist das teilweise auch anders. Aber in dem Film bekommen wir halt alles so serviert, dass wir es gut verstehen können. Das ist zwar dann auch gespickt mit einigen dieser Wörter, zum Beispiel Abkürzungen, die sehr häufig sind. Also Ink Sock, zum Beispiel, das eben für die Weiterentwicklung des englischen Sozialismus steht.
Also Eng.
Na ja, Ink Sock, es schreibt sich tatsächlich Eng.
Ach so, Engeln.
Es ist auch noch eine gewisse orthografische Veränderung dabei. Okay. Und das kommt da vor, da kam Ink Sock vor, dann kam ArtSem vor, ArtSem, Artificial Insemination. Das ist natürlich auch zu lang. Und wenn man das populär machen will, braucht man da ein kurzes Wort.
Also künstliche Befruchtung.
Genau, deshalb ist das eben auch entsprechend da aufgenommen. Ja, und allerdings ist das jetzt alles noch inverständlich, während die eigentliche Sprache, 1984, nach den Vorstellungen Orwells, schon ganz anders klingt. Da sind dann solche Wörter verwendet wie Grime Think und, sagen wir da noch, Duck Speak, da geht es wieder um die Sprache, Belly Feel und so. Belly Feel, ja, das ist... Das Bauchgefühl. Genau, Bauchgefühl, da passt es auch ganz gut. Bauchgefühl ist ein normales deutsches Kompositum, aber Belly Feel geht natürlich nur in Newspeak. In Oldspeak muss das halt irgendwie anders heißen.
Also Newspeak heißt das ja im Original. Kann es sein, dass die deutsche Sprache schon so ein bisschen mehr diesen Charakter hat, wie er es da dem Englischen angedichtet hat, also diese zusammengesetzten Worte?
Ja, das könnte sein. Also solche Zusammensetzungen gehen da halt nicht. Er hatte wohl als Vorbild auch so ein bisschen die Sprache des russischen Kommunismus, wo tatsächlich solche Wortbildungen für die Parteiinstitutionen und so in Russisch gemacht wurden, dass man Versatzstücke von Wörtern zusammengesetzt hat. Also Kompso Molz für die Jugendorganisation, dass man da eben so Silben genommen hat, also schon Abkürzungen. Das ist ein bisschen nachgeahnt. Das geht aber im Deutschen auch, glaube ich, sowieso leichter als im Englischen. Und deshalb wirkt das ein bisschen deutsch, diese Art der Zusammensetzung.
Okay. Hast du den Film auf Deutsch oder auf Englisch angeschaut?
Sowohl als auch.
Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht mehr.
Ich habe ihn mit Sicherheit mal auf Englisch gesehen, das weiß ich ziemlich genau, weil wir den in der Schule mal gesehen haben. Und das war dann auf jeden Fall auf Englisch.
Ich kann ja eigentlich generell nur empfehlen, wenn ein Film auf Englisch ist, und man hat es mit dem Englisch nicht so trotzdem auf Englisch anschauen.
Ja, ich denke auch.
Und mit englischen Untertiteln.
Es ist auch gerade bei Neusprech ein bisschen problematisch, weil das Buch natürlich auch sehr früh nach Deutschland gekommen ist und dann auch übersetzt worden ist. Und da sind dann so Übersetzungen, die halt nicht so... Da weiß man erst gar nicht, was gemeint ist. Also, zum Beispiel heißt Crime-Think in der deutschen Übersetzung Deldenk. Das kann man erstmal gar nicht so richtig...
Ach so Delikt oder was?
Ja, Delikt-Denken, also irgendwie sowas. Das kriegt man nicht so richtig hin. Oder...
Es klang wahrscheinlich, wenn man jetzt in Delikt-Denken, dann klingt es gar nicht neu genug, weil das ein deutsch-Eso ist.
Genau, genau.
Knifflig.
Duck Speak heißt Quack-Sprech. Oder in älteren Übersetzungen Enten-Quack. Das ist natürlich gerade Enten-Quack, Quack hat eigentlich nichts mehr mit dem Charakter von Neusprech zu tun.
Was heißt das Original? Und was ist das?
Duck Speak ist, wenn man einfach plappert.
Ach so, wie eine Ente plappert.
Genau, das spielt eine bestimmte Rolle, dass man einem einfach irgendwas sagt, ohne wirklich grundlegende Konzepte zu berühren.
Enten-Sprech.
Ja, Enten-Sprech wäre eigentlich eine gute Übersetzung, das heißt aber Quack-Sprech.
Quack-Sprech. Enten-Sprech. Das wäre doch mal ein schöner Titel für einen neuen Podcast, den ich machen könnte. Stimmt. Enten-Sprech.
Enten-Sprech, ja.
Damit man nicht über so viel Inhalte bringen muss.
Na ja, kann man natürlich auch Quack-Sprech nennen, wenn man will. Das ist die sozusagen amtliche Übersetzung in der deutschen Fassung von Orwell und älteren Übersetzungen im Enten-Quack. Aber Enten-Quack passt gar nicht, weil da Sprech draußen ist. Na ja, und andere Sachen sind auch komisch. Also Verbrechenstopp oder Unperson. Unperson ist natürlich etwas, was es wirklich auf Deutsch auch gibt. Es ist aber in einer anderen Weise verwendet. Mit der Übersetzung ein bisschen seltsam.
Bleiben wir doch, orientieren wir uns doch am Original. Zumal wir ja auch, ich meine, das ist ja im Computer-Englisch, in unserem neuen Nerdspeak oder Denglisch, oder wie man es auch immer nennt, da ist natürlich das auch so. Dieses Zusammensetzen von Worten und dann natürlich auch dieser ganze Abkürzungskampf. PCMCIA, People Can't Memorize Computer Industry Acronyms.
Genau.
Das ist aber schon in Fleisch und Blut übergegangen. Weshalb hat das wahrscheinlich alles so neu gar nicht mehr vorkommt nach 50 Jahren? Also Orwell war da in jeder Hinsicht sehr zukunftsorientiert.
Sicher, also ich denke, dass er da auch sich Gedanken gemacht hat, wie sich die englische Sprache tatsächlich weiterentwickeln kann und eben auch mit dem Blick auf andere Sprachen. Also ich denke, da steckt schon drin, dass sich Orwell wirklich Gedanken darüber gemacht hat, wie sich das Englische weiterentwickeln kann. Und er lag da vielleicht auch nicht so ganz falsch, weil es tatsächlich solche Bildungen natürlich gibt.
Ja, und, ja, also du weißt nicht, gibt es noch so ein paar Highlights, die jetzt da in Newspeak, jetzt bleiben wir noch mal bei der englischen Bezeichnung, die du jetzt da besonders vielsagend findest?
Ja, gut, man kann natürlich...
Oder die es vielleicht sozusagen in den heutigen Sprachraum tatsächlich geschafft haben.
Ja, also so ein paar Abkürzungswörter sind natürlich durchaus oder kommen einem irgendwie bekannt vor, selbst wenn man das Buch nicht so kennt. Also zum Beispiel die Institutionen werden ja da auch abgekürzt bei Orwell. Also die Ministerium heißen dann eben Minivar und Minilieb und so. Und so ein bisschen ist das natürlich schon auch so, wenn man sich heutige Ministerien anschaut, auch in den demokratischen Ländern, dann heißen die dann eben plötzlich Verteidigungsministerium, weil man ja halt doch ungern Kriegsministerium oder sowas sagt. Dann heißt es eben auch Militärdienst und so. Diese Dinge sind eben bei Orwell auch schon drin. Das Wahrheitsministerium, das ist natürlich das, was Propaganda macht, wird aber Wahrheitsministerium genannt. Und da heißt es dann Friedensministerium, dann sogar noch lateinisch, Minipax. Das ist aber eigentlich das Kriegsministerium. Und das Ministerium, was dort die Rationalisierung macht, da ist ja gerade in Ozeania, da ist ja nun auch gerade Krieg und deshalb müssen alle Leute mit Lebensmittelkarten arbeiten. Das entspricht natürlich auch der Situation von 1948 noch in Großbritannien. Das heißt dann eben Ministerium für Überfluss, also miniplenty, obwohl da gar kein Überfluss ist. Das ist also alles genau verkehrt. Und das sind natürlich Dinge, die man auch tatsächlich in der politischen Propaganda und nicht nur in der Propaganda, sondern eben auch tatsächlich in PR und Marketing. Das ist es eigentlich. Genau.
Das heißt, die Dinge anders darstellen, als sie sind, so ein bisschen schönfärberisch, Euphemismen sagt man eigentlich. Und du siehst das aber auch in der heutigen Zeit, also in unserer Politik jetzt auch stark vertreten.
Das ist eigentlich etwas, was sich wahrscheinlich die Politiker tatsächlich aus der Werbewirtschaft geholt haben und von Image-Beratern oder so. Es ist ja heute so, dass sich viele Politiker da auch beraten lassen und sicherlich auch sprachlich beraten lassen. Und da wird dann eben mal das ein oder andere schlimme Wort durch ein schöneres Wort ersetzt. Also ein Beispiel, was ich besonders auffällig fand, als es dann darum ging, dass irgendwelche Terroristen gezielt getötet werden sollen. Das wurde natürlich dann nicht Schießbefehl genannt, was ein sehr negativer Begriff ist, aber genau das ist es ja. Sondern es wurde dann von Targeted Killing gesprochen. Wobei man an dem Wort sofort erkennt, dass das eigentlich eine Übersetzung eines deutschen Terminus ist. Denn Targeted Killing ist eben gezielte Tötung. Aber auf Englisch klingt das dann gleich viel schöner.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja das Ausweichen auf Englisch in der Hoffnung, dass das keiner so richtig versteht. Ja, das glaube ich nicht. Es gab doch auch diesen Begriff finaler Rettungsschuss.
Genau, da gibt es das auch. Man muss nicht aufs Englische ausweichen. Ich glaube auch, dass in diesem Fall das Ausweichen auf das Englisch nicht dafür da ist, dass man es nicht gut versteht. Sondern einfach dafür da ist, dass es einfach ein bisschen schöner klingt.
Das klingt nach Fachbegriff.
Das klingt nach Fachbegriff. Und es klingt irgendwie, als hätte da jemand sehr viel Zeit investiert, darüber nachzudenken. Und es klingt irgendwie auch frisch und modern. Ich denke, das ist der Grund, warum man da ausweicht. Also ein anderes Beispiel, was ich neulich gehört habe, da geht es darum, dass man irgendwie die Universität reformiert. Und dann gab es den Begriff des Lehrprofessors. Und dann wurde so ein bisschen gewitzelt, Vollprofessor, Lehrprofessor. Und dann sagte ein Minister kürzlich in einer Rede, der Teaching-Only-Professor. Eigentlich ist Teaching-Only-Professor viel klarer, weil es eben auch gleich das Wort nur enthält, das er nur lehren soll. Aber dennoch klingt es irgendwie reizvoller, moderner als Lehrprofessor.
Ich finde das nicht so toll, Teaching-Only. Aber das mag vielleicht an meiner Nähe zur englischen Sprache liegen. Ich finde das schon negativ.
Ja, aber ich denke, es geht nicht um Verständlichkeit. Also Englisch verstehen heute viele Leute. Es geht schon darum, dass es irgendwie modern klingen soll. Das Englische hat oft so eine Konnotation, modern zu sein, das Neueste, weil ja eben Neuigkeiten auch von Wann das kommen. Wir hatten das ja schon mal mit dem Handy. Warum heißt das Handy Handy? Es muss halt irgendwie ein englisches Wort haben. Dabei ist Handy im Englischen gar keine Bezeichnung für ein Telefon.
Gut, aber Handy ist ja kein Begriff, der jetzt von oben installiert wurde. Ich glaube, das ist etwas, was sich einfach hier in Deutschland einfach manifestiert hat. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, woher es herkam. Den gibt es ja im englischsprachigen Raum nicht, diesen Begriff. Also der ist ja nicht so, dass da jetzt wirklich was übernommen wurde, weil es so schön einfach ist, sondern er wurde einfach erfunden. Du kannst nicht nach den USA gehen und nach dem Handy fragen, weil da weiß kein Mensch, was Sache ist.
Es ist wahrscheinlich von Leuten erfunden worden, die da auch vielleicht was verkaufen wollten, die das jetzt vielleicht auch nett fanden, da einen englischen Terminus zu haben. Und dass er sich durchgesetzt hat, zeigt ja, dass die Allgemeinheit auch empfänglich für sowas ist.
Ja gut, da sind wir jetzt aber grundsätzlich eigentlich bei so PR und was kommt halt irgendwie hin. Aber ich meine, das eigentliche Wesen von PR und modernen Marketing, was ja so Anfang dieses letzten Jahrhunderts aufkam, ich hatte das vorhin schon mal erwähnt, mir fällt jetzt leider dieser Name des Dokumentationsfilms nicht an. Vielleicht kommt das noch auf jeden Fall. Da ist so dieses Entstehen des modernen Marketings in New York. Als Reaktion eigentlich auch auf die Lehren von Freud gekommen, der sozusagen die psychische Seite des Menschen vollkommen neu aufgerollt hat. Man muss halt einfach Bilder liefern, man muss Dinge neu besetzen, man muss die positiv besetzen, man muss da halt mal ein Foto-op machen, wie man heute so schön sagt. Man muss ja einfach positive Bilder liefern bzw. eben auch positive Sprache liefern. Also wer will schon eine Müllverbrennungsanlage, das klingt einfach grauenhaft, aber einen Entsorgungspark, da möchte man doch gleich aufatmen. Das ist, glaube ich, so das Wesen der ganzen Geschichte.
Das ist eben genau das, was natürlich dann auch in die Politik geschwappt ist.
Ja, und wo hast du das beobachtet? Wir haben ja hier auch so ein paar, ich weiß nicht, wollen wir dazu, wollen wir schon mal auf ein paar Beispiele kommen an der Stelle? Oder möchtest du da noch was zu einleiten?
Ja, also einleiten kann man vielleicht sagen, dass man einmal natürlich diese Geschichte mit den Wörtern hat, die wir jetzt gerade schon hatten. Und das ist natürlich auch, wie gesagt, auf beiden Seiten sozusagen, auch wenn man also selber gegen die Strömung was machen will. Also wenn man sagen will, wir wollen was gegen Online-Untersuchung, Online-Durchsuchung tun, dann kann man da vielleicht auch mal über Wörter nachdenken. Also was wie Computer, Wanze und so, das klingt dann schon irgendwie griffiger. Oder Bundestrojaner, was wir ja nun schon haben. Das ist einmal auf der Ebene der Wörter, aber es sind natürlich nicht nur die Wörter, sondern das, denke ich, sieht man nachher auch ganz schön an den Beispielen. Es wird auch in einer gewissen Weise, es gibt auch so eine gewisse Rhetorik, die jetzt gerade in der politischen Diskussion eine sehr starke Rolle spielt. Da gibt es einmal so reinsprachliche Dinge, dass zum Beispiel mit Pronomina so gearbeitet wird. Da sind immer wir und die anderen, also die Täter und wir und so. Eine solche Gegenüberstellung. Und dann gibt es auch Fragen der Argumentation, also sehr viele Formen von Scheinargumenten, die sehr häufig und sehr gerne benutzt werden. Dass man also zum Beispiel ablenkt in der Argumentation und plötzlich Ablenkungsmanöver durchführt, über ganz andere Dinge spricht, über die man sprechen will.
Das ist ja auch generell der Politiker-Sprech, wenn man immer wieder so schön feststellt. Es wird eine Frage gestellt und die Antwort, wenn man sie sich danach nochmal auf der Zunge zergehen lässt, geht einfach auf die Frage nicht ein. Generell gilt ja auch ein PR. Man antwortet nicht mehr, sondern man wartet immer nur auf den richtigen Moment, wo man seine Message, wie man so schön sagt, platzieren kann, wo man seine eigene Mitteilung macht. Und man macht halt möglichst auch mit jedem Satz eine solche Mitteilung. Versucht sie irgendwie nur so halbwegs gut zu platzieren.
Genau. Naja, und dann eben die Argumentation, dass man verschiedene Dinge miteinander vermischt, ausweicht auf ein ganz anderes Thema, zu dem gar nicht gefragt worden ist. Und die Sachen so vermischt, dass der andere dann irgendwie sagt, ja, der wird voll recht haben. Ich meine, das ist, glaube ich, ein schöner, da können wir direkt auch schon mal was hören. Wir könnten ja mal da diese Argumentation zur Online-Überwachung hören, wo man, wo das tatsächlich auch sehr schön gemacht wird.
Okay, dann machen wir das doch mal. Womit fangen wir denn...
Dann hören wir uns doch mal den Ziercke an. Da kann man, glaube ich, alles schon schön aufzeigen. Also gerade diese Argumentation.
Aus seines Zeichens, Chef vom BKA, der ist ja irgendwie sehr schön hinterher bei Online-Durchsuchungen und ähnlichen Sachen.
Ja, das will er natürlich unbedingt.
Dann sagen wir doch mal die geheime Zahl, die wir hier vorher abgesprochen haben.
Wir können ruhig mit der 1 anfangen. Da ist zwar jetzt noch nicht so sprachlich... Da ist schon was Sprachliches drin. Das ist jetzt nicht das, was ich meinte, mit der Verschiebung, aber wir könnten da einmal anfangen, dann haben wir es auch chronologisch. Und da kann man sehr schön auch schon einen Punkt sehen, wie zum Beispiel so eine Wissenschaftlichkeit hergestellt wird, in dem plötzlich mit Zahlen operiert wird. Dummerweise vergreift er sich so ein bisschen bei den Zahlen.
Sagen wir es einmal dazu. Wir haben die Zitate aus einem Deutschlandfunk-Interview rausgenommen. Das ist jetzt nicht das ganze Interview, sondern wir haben jetzt einfach mal nur stellenweise seinen O-Truhen rausgenommen, weil uns interessiert ja eigentlich nur das, was er sagt und nicht das, was gefragt wird. Das spielt ja eh keine Rolle mehr.
Es geht um Online-Durchsuchung.
Ja, ich denke, die Polizeipraxis bedürftigt zur Bekämpfung des internationalen Terrorismus und der organisierten Kriminalität, also schwerster sozialschädlicher Form der Kriminalität, auch die Online-Durchsuchung. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die Menschen in Deutschland Angst davor haben, müssen jetzt durch den Staat in einer Weise überwacht zu werden, die nicht mehr den Rechtsgrundsätzen entspricht. 99,9 Prozent der Menschen in Deutschland werden von dieser Maßnahme, auch von Telefonüberwachungsmaßnahmen, überhaupt nicht betroffen sein.
Ja, da sieht man schon sehr schön. Einmal, dass er mit Schlagwörtern arbeitet, dass auch feste Fügungen dabei sind. Also internationaler Terrorismus. Das ist einfach nicht Terrorismus, sondern internationaler Terrorismus. Und wenn man sich da fragt, wenn es jetzt hier um Online-Durchsuchung in Deutschland geht, gut, ja.
Schwerste, sozialschädliche...
Ja.
99,9 Prozent.
Das ist natürlich der Höhepunkt, 99,9 Prozent. Das klingt natürlich besser, als wenn er sagt, da ist ja fast niemand betroffen oder so. Aber wenn er 99,9 Prozent sagt, dann klingt das wie, ja, da ist ja wirklich niemand betroffen. Aber wenn man das jetzt ausrechnet, kommt man immer bei 80 Millionen Deutschen auf 80.000 Menschen, die da ständig überwacht werden. Wenn man sagt, bei 100.000 geht die Großstadt los, ist das fast eine Großstadt, die komplett überwacht wird. Das ist natürlich...
Da ist nur eine Großstadt Deutschlands von betroffen. Das klingt doch gleich ganz anders.
Das klingt gleich ganz anders, genau. Also das ist natürlich irgendwie schon ein Griff in die Rhetorikkiste, den man sich vielleicht besser überlegen sollte. Ich weiß es nicht, ob das jemanden nachrechnet oder ob dann gleich alle überzeugt sind dadurch.
Wollen wir gleich weitermachen mit dem jungen Mann? Schauen wir mal, was er sonst noch zum technischen Fortschritt sozusagen hat.
Wir müssen mit dem technischen Fortschritt Schritt halten können, wenn skripulose Kriminelle ins Internet ausweichen und dort ihre Anschlagsplanung, ihre kriminelle Handlung vorbereiten.
Oh, jetzt weichen sie ins Internet aus.
Genau, das ist schon das Erstaunliche. Das ist eben genau so eine Form der Argumentation. Das ist eine Scheinargumentation, nämlich das Ablenkungsmanöver. Das ist ja auch eine typische Form von Scheinargumentation. Es wird auf etwas ganz anderes ausgewichen. Es ging gerade um die Online-Durchsuchung und jetzt geht es plötzlich ums Internet. Und wie wir dann gleich noch hören, ist damit tatsächlich das Internet gemeint, was jeder einsehen kann, wofür man überhaupt keine Online-Durchsuchung braucht. Und es geht dann gleich um Bombenbauanleitungen und so.
Und das ist dann technischer Fortschritt.
Das ist dann technischer Fortschritt, genau. Also auch das mit dem technischen Fortschritt passt da nicht gut rein. Das ist eben auch wieder eine Phrase. Wir müssen Schritt halten mit dem technischen Fortschritt. Das ist an sich ja kein Argument. Beziehungsweise ist das ja selbstverständlich.
Ich meine, durchaus könnte der Staat das ab und zu auch mal tun, so mit dem technischen Fortschritt. Aber vielleicht nicht unbedingt jetzt in diesem Bereich.
Ja. Naja, es ist halt ein Allgemeinplatz, dass man mithalten soll mit dem technischen Fortschritt. Das muss jeder tun.
Da sagt dann auch jeder gleich Ja.
Da sagt jeder sofort Ja. Was das eigentlich bedeutet, das sagt er nicht. Beziehungsweise er geht plötzlich ein aufs Internet. Und im nächsten Beispiel, das ist also sehr, sehr interessant, geht es zunächst weiter ums Internet und dann wird das plötzlich konspirativ. Also auf der einen Seite sind die Dinge ganz öffentlich zugreifbar und plötzlich alles verschlüsselt. Da fragt man sich ja, was meint der jetzt eigentlich? Und dann wird das Ganze noch schön abgerundet. Tatsächlich durch Fach-Vokabular der Ermittlungsbehörden, wie er dann ja auch selber sagt. Dann wird von dem Milieu gesprochen, von verdeckten Ermittlungen. Dann hat er noch so einen Termin, den ich noch nicht gehört habe.
Dann hören wir doch einfach mal rein. Nicht, dass wir uns jetzt hier auch noch auf das falsche Soundsample beziehen. Das ist so eine lange Liste. Aber wir waren ganz saugfältig. Also, Ziercke, sprich.
Ja, ich würde Ihnen das am Beispiel der Terrorismusbekämpfung mal deutlich machen. Wir finden heute im Internet Bombenbauanleitungen, wir finden Anschlagspläne, wir finden Aufträge für die Durchführung von Anschlägen, Propaganda, die Ideologisierung, also die Rekrutierung junger Menschen zum Jihad als Suizidattentäter. Das Internet ist das entscheidende Kommunikationsmittel des Internets und Terrorismus. Und die Szene arbeitet hochkonspirativ. Das heißt, sie arbeitet verdeckt, sie verschlüsselt, sie anonymisiert. Und für die polizeiliche Arbeit ist es heute schon sehr schwierig, durch Observationen im Milieu zum Beispiel überhaupt den Anfasser für Ermittlungen zu bekommen, wie wir sagen. Das heißt, das Eindring in Milieus mit verdeckten Ermittlern, also mit Polizeibeamten, das ist fast unmöglich.
Wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, was er eigentlich an Argumenten geliefert hat, hat er gar nichts geliefert. Er hat davon gesprochen, dass das Internet alles Mögliche enthält und dass man da ja was tun muss.
Da sind Bombenbauanleitungen drin.
Dann sind die aber plötzlich verschlüsselt. Sicher sind die gefährlich.
Anschlagspläne.
Das Thema ist Online-Durchsuchung. Das Ausspionieren von Festplatten.
Aber da ist doch auch Propaganda im Internet. Willst du uns im internationalen Terrorismus einfach so schutzlos ausliefern?
Aber das ist, wie gesagt, das andere Thema. Er mischt das einfach nach Gusto. Dann kommt gleich wieder was Konspiratives, Verschlüsseltes. Die Bombenbauanleitungen sind aber nicht verschlüsselt.
Ich finde es bemerkenswert, was die alles im Internet gefunden haben. Also Suizid-Attentäter und Ideologisierung auf Weyer. Also, ich meine, als ob alle anderen Medien davon so frei wären.
Genau. Und allein die Ideologisierung rechtfertigt dann online durchspielen.
Propaganda sogar.
Also Ideologisierung.
Aber er wiederholt, er hat jetzt auch schon das zweite Mal den internationalen Terrorismus gemacht.
Genau, das Nachwort kommt auch nur so. Immer in der Kombination. Das wird nicht von Terrorismus gesprochen, sondern von internationalem Terrorismus. Das ist das Schlagwort. Und das wird dann auch nicht weiter hinterfragt.
Ja, ich freu mich, ob der so sehr viel anders ist als der nationale Terrorismus. Da haben wir ja nun auch durchuntergegangen. Ich find's auch bemerkenswert, dass da dann eben auch gleich noch Verschlüsselung. Es wird verschlüsselt, es wird anonymisiert. Also so auf der einen Seite kommt jetzt so der Schwarzmann. Ja, ich öffne das Buch Internet und auf einmal sind da irgendwie Bomben bastelnde von Propaganda und Idealisierungen durchwirkte Suizidattentäter, die hochkonspirativ arbeiten. Das finde ich jetzt mal besonders interessant. Also schauen Sie uns Internet, jenseits des technischen Fortschritts, weil den brauchen Sie ja jetzt erst noch, und stellen fest, also Sie sehen alles das, obwohl es verschlüsselt und anonymisiert ist.
Ja, weil das passt nicht.
Fragt man sich, wie Sie das eigentlich wissen, dass das so ist, wenn das alles verschlüsselt und anonymisiert ist. Da kann man natürlich sagen, Sie haben da mal einen Rechner aufgemacht, und dann haben Sie da gesehen, dass da jemand Tor installiert hat, und dann hat er irgendwie PGP benutzt.
Naja, beim ersten Teil seiner Ausführungen geht es natürlich tatsächlich darum, dass man einfach so Bomben-Anleitungen finden kann im Internet, und dass einfach so im Internet Leute angesprochen werden und geworben werden. Das ist natürlich nicht gleichzusetzen mit der konspirativen oder mit der verschlüsselten Seite.
Ist denn das schon so ein Neusprech? Also ist so, würdest du jetzt so internationaler Terrorismus, würdest du das so unter Kategorie Neusprech?
In größer Weise gehört das zu solchen Schlagwörtern, die in ihrer Bedeutung nicht mehr so ganz klar sind. Also das ist schon das Feindbild, was nicht klar definiert ist.
Ja, wie auch Al-Qaeda ja nun wirklich nicht gerade besonders klar definiert ist.
Ja, Al-Qaeda, da muss man sich nochmal vorstellen, wo das herkommt. Al-Qaeda ist eigentlich das Wort für Datenbank. Und das ist halt aufgekommen, so wird berichtet, aber ich denke, das ist plausibel.
Wie Al-Qaeda ist das Wort für Datenbank?
Das ist das arabische Wort für Datenbank, ja. Al-Qaeda heißt Datenbank.
Echt?
Ja, du kannst ja in der Wikipedia nachschauen unter Al-Qaeda. Nein, aber es ist tatsächlich so. Das Wort ist halt aufgekommen, als man die ersten Verhöre gemacht hat. Da gab es das Konzept noch gar nicht. Dann ging es darum, dass gesagt wurde, der steht auch in der Adressenliste, der gehört auch in die Datenbank. Dann hat möglicherweise der Übersetzer oder wie auch immer, der wusste vielleicht nicht genau, was das ist, weil das ein bisschen schwierig ist mit den Neologismen im Arabischen. Die sind auch nicht für alle Leute immer gleich klar. Wenn das zum Beispiel jemand übersetzt, der diese Neologismen nicht kennt, weil er sich in einem anderen Bereich des Arabischen umtreibt, dann weiß er nicht genau, was das ist. Irgendwie ist das dann als Synonym für die Organisation aufgekommen, die es am Anfang als Organisation so gar nicht gab. Es ist ja bis heute so, dass wir es damit zellen zu tun haben, die irgendwie locker zusammenhängen. Es wird uns zwar immer gesagt, da gibt es eine große böse Organisation, Al-Qaeda, aber eine Organisation in dem Sinne, wie die irisch-republikanische Armee oder so, ist es ja gar nicht.
Terrornetzwerk.
Ja, Netzwerk, gut, Netzwerk. Das sagt sich schon, dass es ein bisschen lockerer ist. Aber das Netzwerk, das sehen wir ja gleich auch noch, wenn wir das nächste Ziercke-Zitat hören, da wird auch von Netzwerken gesprochen und sehr doppeldeutig. Man weiß nicht genau, meint er jetzt das Internet als Netzwerk? Aber was da zerschlagen werden soll, sind irgendwie die terroristischen Netzwerke, also Personen, die in einem zusammenhalten sind.
Die Terror-Datenbank, Terror-VZ. Terror-VZ muss zerschlagen werden. Also die Alvissene Müllhalde zitiert auch noch die Begriffe Basis, Regel, Stützpunkt, Fundament, aber auch Datenbank.
Ja, also Database, daher kommt das natürlich. Database, Basis, und dann hat man halt dieses Wort dafür genommen.
Fundament. Gut, nimm Kriegsschau Platz.
Ja, nie, aber das ist ja auch interessant, wie solche Wörter entstehen. Das ist genau dasselbe Thema. Man braucht eben auch, ich wollte das gleich nochmal mit dem Pronominar zeigen bei einem anderen Zitat, man muss eben auch Dinge gegenüberstellen. Also wir und die anderen. Und wenn die anderen einen Namen haben, dann sind die gleich schon besser darzustellen. Oder man kann die dann besser eben auch in einen Gegensatz rücken zu den anderen.
Wir brauchen einen neuen Feind.
Wir brauchen einen Feind, und der muss einen Namen haben. Das ist ja immer die Frage, geht es da nur um Sprache oder auch um Inhalte? Aber Sprache und Inhalte sind halt miteinander verbunden. Und deshalb ist es eben auch wichtig, dass man Inhalte mit Sprache prägt. Und die Inhalte prägen natürlich auch Sprache. Das ist ganz klar. Und hier wird es tatsächlich so gemacht. Al-Kaida ist da ein schönes Beispiel. Und wir werden das gleich noch, wir können auch gleich hingehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du da direkt hinspringen kannst. Wir haben da ja auch so ein Merkel-Zitat. Und da ist das sehr schön gemacht. Da sind verschiedene Gruppen genannt. Und sie baut da tatsächlich so ein Gegenüber auf. Mithilfe von sprachlichen Mitteln natürlich. Also wir auf der einen Seite. Und dann werden Personengruppen auf der anderen Seite genannt. Und dann fühlt man sich plötzlich auch in so einer Lage, dass man sagt, oh ja, da sind die, gegen die wir was machen müssen. Und wir sind wir. Und wir wollen das so haben.
Ja, bleiben wir vielleicht nochmal bei Ziercke mit seinen Netzwerken. Weil die zieht er jetzt im nächsten Beispiel an.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wenn dort Beweise vorhanden sind für solche Anschläge, für solche Anschlagsplanung, für Propaganda, dann muss ich in der Lage sein, die Netzwerke des Terrorismus auch auf diese Art und Weise zu zerschlagen. Wenn ich nur mit Telefonüberwachungsmaßnahmen komme und von vornherein weiß, dass man das Internet ausweicht, oder wenn ich weiß, dass ich ins Milieu nicht eindringen kann mit verdeckten Ermittlern und gleichzeitig über das Problem habe, dass Anschläge vorbereitet werden, dann muss ich, um sozusagen vor die Lage zu kommen, um Gefahren auf der einen Seite abzuwehren, aber auch Beweise zu verdichten, damit auch eine Strafverurteilung stattfinden kann, dann muss ich auch im Internet bei solchen Menschen jedenfalls, die schwer kriminell sind, mit einem richterlichen Beschluss natürlich, nicht Polizei auf eigene Veranlassung hin eine solche Durchsuchung durchführen.
Ja, jetzt sind wir wieder bei der Untersuchung. Wir kamen gerade vom Internet und jetzt sind wir wieder bei der Durchsuchung von Festplatten. Das ist eben das Interessante, dass er so in einem Bogen da immer hin und her gleitet und man weiß gar nicht genau...
Na gut, man könnte ihm zu gut erhalten, dass das natürlich jetzt auch so seine Argumentationskette nun mal ist. Da draußen lauert das Böse. Wir haben den größtmöglichen Feind, den man sich nur vorstellen kann, die Datenbank und Terror-VZ. Und die wollen jetzt... die wollen uns irgendwie quer kommen. Die bauen Bomben und sie kriechen geradezu durch das Internet in unser Land hinein. So klingt das.
Das sind aber alles so Bilder. Wenn man die genauer analysiert, passt das alles nicht.
Ich habe ja echt Zweifel. Ich will ja gar nicht so viel ausschließen. Das kann ja auch alles irgendwie sein. Aber Anschlagsplanung im Internet? Das kauf ich einfach nicht ab. Wie bekloppt müssen die denn sein? Was ist mit Papier und Zettel passiert? Taucht das alles nicht mehr? Verschlüsselte Telefone gibt es auch zu kaufen. Das ist alles nicht mehr die Technologie. Das Geld ist sicherlich da. Ich kenne mich nicht aus mit Terrorismus. Aber diese Anschläge liegen im Internet.
Das ist auch nicht so.
Die Online-Durchsuchung ist ja auch gar nicht eine Attacke aufs Internet. Es ist eine Attacke auf Rechner.
Die heimische Festplatte, die am besten gar nicht verschlüsselt ist und gar nicht für das Internet zugänglich.
Er redet auch fortwährend von Schwerstkriminellen. Hochgradig, sozialschädlich. Was das sein soll, ist mir noch nicht ganz klar. Die Entscheidung zur Online-Durchsuchung, die viel beachtete und auch in Chaosradio 132 übrigens auch umfangreich diskutierte, die war ja eigentlich sehr erfreulich. Sie wurde interessanterweise mal wieder von beiden Seiten bejubelt. Das gehört, glaube ich, auch zur politischen Reaktion heutzutage. Man muss immer Gewinner sein. Ich bedanke mich bei meinen WLAN und so weiter.
Ich bedanke mich bei den Verfassungsrichtern, die jetzt für eine Klarstellung gesorgt haben. Man wird auch nicht näher darauf eingegangen, was die Klarstellung eigentlich ist.
Aber jetzt ist zumindest alles klar.
Jetzt ist alles klar. Das wird dann als positiv dargestellt, was sicherlich auch positiv ist. Aber es ist nicht das, was der Politiker, der das jetzt so lobt, wollte. Er ist abgewatscht worden. Ich bedanke mich aber jetzt für die Klarstellung. Das ist schon...
Trickreich. Wollen wir nochmal weitermachen hier?
Das Internet ist das Tatmittel der Zukunft. Es ist jetzt schon im Grunde.
Das Tatmittel der Zukunft? Eigentlich jetzt schon.
Ja, genau. Denn wenn es das Tatmittel der Zukunft wäre, wäre man ja sozusagen der Zeit voraus. Und das fällt ihm dann gerade noch so ein. Er hat erst das Schlagwort gewartet, das Tatmittel der Zukunft. Und dann, nee, es ist ja jetzt schon.
Das war ja sozusagen schon fast ein kleiner Lapsus.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist ein Lapsus. Das wollte er so nicht sagen. Deshalb hat er sich anschließend auch korrigiert. Aber es kommt jetzt noch was Schöneres an Lapsus. Bei Nummer 6, da versetzt sich Herr Ziercke nämlich in den Terroristen. Er spricht plötzlich von seinem, meinem Computer. Er sagt, in meinem Computer. Und da fragt man sich wirklich, was will er uns damit sagen. Und dann kommt auch noch was Schönes. Wir hatten ja vorhin immer vom internationalen Terrorismus die Rede. Und plötzlich wird alles andere noch mit da reingenommen. Was er macht, wo er nichts mehr hat. Das ist wirklich auch klasse, wie sich da so die Kategorien verschieben.
Wir hören hin.
Wenn wir auf der einen Seite Milieus nicht richtig eindringen können, aus bekannten Gründen, die ich schon dargestellt habe, dann bleibt ja nur die Möglichkeit, über die Beweise, die zum Beispiel in einem Computer gespeichert sind, Gefahren abzuwehren und Anfangsverdachtslagen, wie wir sagen, zu verdichten, um an die Netzwerke heranzukommen. Nicht nur den Einzeltäter, sondern das Netzwerk, die Gruppierung, die dahinter steckt. Und das gilt nicht nur für den Terrorismus. Sie können das übertragen auf den Bereich der Kinderpornografie als der schwersten Form der Kindesmisshandlung zum Beispiel, auf rechtsextremistische Propaganda im Internet, die immer mehr zunimmt. Sie können das übertragen auf die Wirtschaftsspionage, auf Wirtschaftskommission, auf Frauenhandel, auf Menschenhandel. Ich sage aber noch mal ganz deutlich, 99,9 Prozent der Menschen in Deutschland haben mit dieser Maßnahme überhaupt nicht zu tun. Es geht hier wirklich um Schwierkriminalität. Ich möchte eine Rechtsgrundlage, die es einem Richter erlaubt, mir diese Ermächtigung zu geben. Nicht die Polizei aus eigener Verkommenheit möchte das.
Nicht die Polizei aus eigener Verkommenheit. Hat er gesagt.
Ich glaube, er wollte Vollkommenheit sein. Weil er glaubt, die Polizei sei vollkommen. Die Polizei fühlt sich vollkommen, ist es aber nicht. Irgendwie so etwas wollte er eigentlich sagen.
Aber er hat jetzt natürlich wirklich die Klassiker wieder auf den Tisch gelegt. Das kann man ja nicht häufig genug betonen. Ich kenne auch keine Organisation, die nicht damit hochkommt. Gab es ja damals schon in den frühen Internetzeiten diesen Fall mit diesem Anonymous-Remailer, anon.v, wo diese Scientology-Dokumente verbreitet wurden und Scientologies dann doch halbwegs effektive Maßnahmen dem Einhalt zu gebieten waren, ihn dann einfach wegen Kinderpornografie, also Verbreitung von Kinderpornografie anzuzeigen, woraufhin die Bullen dann gleich eingeritten sind und ja, erstmal die Kiste mitgenommen haben. Und das findet man halt auch immer wieder. Weil es etwas ist, wo jeder sagt, das darf nicht sein.
Jaja, das sagt jeder. Obwohl, übrigens wahrscheinlich juristisch gesehen, Kinderpornografie ist keine Schwerstkriminalität. Ist so schlimm, es ist. Aber das ist, glaube ich, von der Definition her was anderes. Aber es kommt ja dann, er nennt ja auch noch andere Dinge, wie Wirtschaftsspionage oder Propaganda.
Die Propaganda hat er in diesem Moment nicht genannt, das hat er dafür hingesagt. Er hat KIPO, also Kinderpornografie, Nazis, Wirtschaftskriminalität. Finde ich aber ganz bemerkenswert, dass das jetzt mittlerweile schon auf dem Level von Nazis ist.
Das würde ja bedeuten, dass jemand, der sein Geld nach Lichtenstein schafft, ein Schwerstkriminalist ist.
Ist er auch. Also na gut, es ist auf jeden Fall ein Krimineller, wir sind schwer. Diese Dinge lassen sich eigentlich nicht vergleichen. Und insofern sind solche Vergleiche auch schwierig. Aber es ist halt so dieses, wer jetzt bei internationaler Terrorismus noch nicht schreiend auf die Straße gelaufen ist, der zieht also spätestens dann sein Schwert aus dem Schrank, wenn Nazis und Kinderpornografie auf einmal kommen. Und weil es halt gerade so schön passt, wir haben ganz böse Manager, dann ist es eben jetzt auch noch die Leute, die uns irgendwie das Geld wegnehmen und unsere Frauen am besten auch noch.
Ja, es wird alles einfach zusammengeworfen. Das ist sicherlich auch...
Aber kann man es ihm verdenken? Also ich meine, er ist ja Polizist. Und er möchte ja gerne ran. Man könnte ja auch positiv unterstellen, er macht halt einfach die bestmögliche PR, um einfach am Ende zumindest irgendwas zu bekommen, mit dem er was tun kann. Weil er wird ja gemessen daran, welchen Erfolg er hat.
Ja, also es soll natürlich hier kein Ziercke-Bashing sein. Es ist natürlich schon so, dass er gewisse Interessen vertritt. Und gerade der Chef des Bundeskriminalamts, von dem hat man natürlich nichts anderes zu erwarten. Er hat praktisch beruflich den Auftrag, die Interessen des Bundeskriminalamts zu verteidigen.
Ja gut, aber die Interessen des Bundeskriminalamts sind ja auch die Interessen dieses Staates. Und insofern muss er ja auch die Interessen des Staates vertreten.
Es ging ja hier jetzt mal um die Frage, wie argumentiert wird. Und es wird eben eigentlich nicht argumentiert, sondern es wird die ganze Zeit mit Ablenkungsmanövern gearbeitet. Und das ist eben nicht so ganz richtig. Also ich denke, man kann sicherlich auch tatsächlich Argumente für die Anliegen des Bundeskriminalamts finden. Er macht das nun nicht so richtig. Er geht hier eigentlich immer auf so... Es sind wirklich ständig Ablenkungsmanöver, die er hat. Also Scheinargumente.
Ja gut, aber wenn wir jetzt nochmal... Ich will jetzt hier nicht den Teufels-Gegenspieler spielen, aber so Kinderpornografie, der Klassiker ist ja immer so, wir finden dann die Bilder auf der Festplatte. So als der ultimative Beweis. Das will ich ja auch überhaupt nicht in Abrede stellen. Das natürlich so... Durch das es jetzt mit dem Rechner so schön einfach ist, diese Daten zu speichern, was wahrscheinlich die meisten Leute auch tun. Also die Fotoalben, die so unter dem Parkettboden versteckt sind, das ist wahrscheinlich echt die Ausnahme. Und da will er ran.
Ja, gut. Ich meine, man ist ja nicht gegen polizeiliche Aufklärung. Das kann natürlich auch gemacht werden. Nur es soll eben nicht lahmheimlich passieren, so wie jetzt geplant, dass dann irgendwie per Bundestrojaner eben man tatsächlich Computer verwanzt und heimlich abhört. Also ich meine, dann ist natürlich irgendwann der Rechtsstaat wirklich außer Kraft gesetzt. Also es soll schon so sein, dass rechtsstaatliche Mittel verwendet werden.
Da ist er ja auch dabei. Sein Abschlusswort stellt ja auch wieder alles rosig-blumig dar. Vielleicht werfen wir das nochmal hinterher. Dann haben wir Herrn Ziercke auch abgearbeitet. Gucken wir mal, wie er endet.
Und selbstverständlich, dass durch den Richter, durch den Staatsanwalt und durch die Polizei die Bürgerrechte geschützt werden. Und der Datenschützer kann diese Maßnahmen selbstverständlich überprüfen.
Das war mir neu. Also dass irgendwie Datenschützer jetzt in der Lage sind, die Tätigkeit des BKA zu überprüfen. Ich glaube, da würde jeder Datenschützer ein bisschen im Dreieck springen. Das ist ihm wahrscheinlich komplett neu. Das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen. Aber es sind ja die Richter drin. Das ist ja diese tolle Sache mit dem Richtervorbehalten. Wir wollten ja eigentlich sehr viel mehr über die Sprache reden, aber man kommt irgendwie auch am Thema nicht so vorbei. Gerade diese Richter-Geschichte ist etwas, was die Leute ja immer, was glaube ich auch so ein bisschen Propaganda ist. Was wollt ihr denn eigentlich? Da sind doch Richter am Start. Und wenn ein Richter da ist, das klingt so, als würden da so fünf kleine Polizistchen auf Fahrräder da herkommen und dann steht so ein 30-Meter-Hühner-Richter vor ihnen mit einem Buch da im Arm und sagt, na na na na, habt ihr denn auch das Formular komplett ausgefüllt? Ja, haben wir. Okay, super, ich schaue mir das mal an. Büffelt dann irgendwie stundenlang und setzt dann irgendwann so sein großes rotes Siegel da drunter und dann dürfen sie losziehen. In Wahrheit ist das so ein Fünf-Minuten-Akt. Da liegt dann irgendwie so ein Stapel mit 30 solchen Verfügung und dann wird dann irgendwie schnell noch mal am Freitagabend eine Unterschrift nach dem anderen geleistet und gut ist.
Ja, aber hier ist ja noch schlimmer, wenn du das nochmal genau hörst, hat er drei Dinge ineinander gestellt. Durch die Richter, die Staatsanwaltschaft und die Polizei. Das sind aber sehr verschiedene...
Staatsanwalt hat er das gesagt?
Doch, er hat drei Sachen genannt. Durch die Richter, Staatsanwalt...
Ich spiele es nochmal kurz ab.
Und selbstverständlich, dass durch den Richter, durch den Staatsanwalt und durch die Polizei die Bürgerrechte geschützt werden. Und der Datenschützer kann diese Maßnahmen selbstverständlich überprüfen.
Also der Richter, der Staatsanwalt und die Polizei. Das sind ja völlig unterschiedliche Dinge. Der Richter ist ja die Jurisdiktion. Also eine Gewalt und die Staatsanwaltschaft. Der Staatsanwalt ist ja direkt abhängig von der Exekutive. Das heißt, er macht das, was seine Vorgesetzten letztlich der Innenminister will.
Das muss er machen.
Der Staatsanwalt ist abhängig von der Exekutive. Die Polizei ist die Exekutive. Die Polizei gehört auch zur Exekutive. Es sind zweimal die Exekutive genannt, die ja gerade kontrolliert werden müssen. Der Staatsanwalt und die Polizei müssen kontrolliert werden. Dafür ist der Richter da. Der kontrolliert, was die anderen machen. Das ist aber hier einfach gleichgesetzt. Gewaltenteilung wird aufgehoben. Richter, Staatsanwalt und Polizei machen dasselbe, schützen den Bürger. Das hat er gesagt. Aber das ist nicht so ganz, wie es eigentlich sein soll. Also auch da wieder so eine Verschiebung. Damit wird einem dann wieder verkauft, dass die Polizei das schon selbst irgendwie hinkriegt. Oder der Staatsanwalt selbst hinkriegt. Ohne den Richter vielleicht, unter Umständen.
Siehst du da wirklich so ein durchgehendes Schema? Sprechen die sich irgendwie ab? Oder ist das einfach nur mittlerweile so eingedickt in der Politikkultur, dass die gar nicht mehr anders können?
Ja, also wenn man diese Phrasen sieht, die wir immer wieder haben, und die natürlich vielleicht auch noch bei den anderen Teilnehmern kommen, also tatsächlich ganz ähnliche oder sogar dieselben Phrasen, dann brauchen wir, glaube ich, nicht abzusprechen. Dann ist es schon so, dass gewisse Begrifflichkeiten da einfach wirklich wie in Form eines Neuspreches immer wieder kommen und nicht mehr weiter reflektiert werden.
Wem hören wir denn als nächstes zu?
Ja, weil ich vorhin schon mal davon gesprochen habe, würde ich direkt mit der Frau Merkel weitermachen.
Das Merkel, ja, die hat, das ist für dich eine Bemerkung. Was war das eigentlich? War das eine Wahlkampfveranstaltung?
Das kann sein. Es war in Niedersachsen, also da war ja Wahlkampf und da ist sie in Osnabrück aufgetreten. Und ich glaube, das war eine Wahlkampfveranstaltung. Es kann aber auch was direkt von der CDU gewesen sein. Aber sie stellt die Union neben das Wir. Sie ist sicherlich auf einer CDU-Veranstaltung, aber wenn man sich genau überlegt, was will sie eigentlich mit Wir sagen, ist das, glaube ich, eine größere Gruppe als die Union. Wir sind wir alle die Bürger. Das ist auch ganz typisch für die gegenwärtige Politik, denke ich. Das hat vielleicht auch etwas mit Populismus zu tun, ich weiß es nicht genau, aber dass eben alle mit Wir angeredet werden. Also Wir, der Politiker. Da gehören wir dazu. Dafür sind wir uns angesprochen. Das ist ein sogenanntes inklusives Wir. Es gibt ja noch mal das exklusive Wir. Das exklusive Wir ist halt nur der Sprecher und seine Gruppe. Also zum Beispiel wir die CDU und ihr die Sozialdemokratie. Das ist das exklusive Wir. Und dann gibt es das inklusive Wir, was den Angesprochenen mit einschließt. Und das gebraucht sich hier. Das ist, glaube ich, ganz deutlich. Wir alle. Also unser Staat, wir.
Ja, dann hören wir doch mal rein.
Das werden wir uns nicht davon abbringen lassen. Sie werden sich erinnern, die Älteren unter Ihnen, wie viele Schlachten wir schon geschlagen haben.
Die Videoüberwachung.
Gestritten mit den Sozialdemokraten. Heute hätten wir weder die libanesischen Kofferbomber gefunden, noch hätten wir die Schlägereien des alten Mannes in der U-Bahn in München so schnell aufklären können. Und heute findet jeder Videoüberwachung auf großen öffentlichen Plätzen ganz normal. Wenn es die Union nicht gewesen wäre, die dafür gekämpft hätte, dass das notwendig ist, hätten wir heute noch keine Videoüberwachung. Deshalb werden wir auch andere Themen auf die Tagesordnung bringen, wie bestimmte Veränderungen im Jugendstrafrecht, genauso wie die Online-Durchsuchung und vieles andere mehr. Wir werden nicht zulassen, dass technisch manches möglich ist, aber der Staat es nicht nutzt dafür, aber die Verbrecher und Täter und Terroristen es nutzen.
Ja, also da sieht man das. Am Anfang war tatsächlich wir die CDU. Das sagt sie ja, wir die CDU. Aber dann kommt sie, dann wird das wir plötzlich allgemein. Und dann sagt sie eben, das ist nicht unser Staat. Der Staat muss wehrhaft bleiben. Da sind dann wir alle gemeint.
Also das ist ja wirklich auch echt der totale Knaller. Da atme ich schwer, wenn ich das höre. Also erstmal, was ich hier großartig finde, ist am Anfang schon dieser Bogen Videoüberwachung. Das haben wir ja durchgesetzt gegen die ganzen Bösen. Die Sozialdemokraten zum Beispiel. Das klingt schon fast wie internationaler Terrorismus.
Aber aufsprachlich muss man das sehen. Sie sagt die Sozialdemokratie. Das ist also auch eigentlich ein Terminus, der nicht passt. Und die Sozialdemokratie ist ja eigentlich die Ideologie der Sozialdemokraten. Das ist fast wie der Kommunismus. Wir und die Sozialdemokratie. Die dritte Gruppe sind die Verbrecher, Täter und Terroristen. Das ist eine schöne Steigung. Verbrecher, Täter, Terroristen.
Ich strauche da jetzt gerade ein bisschen. Lustig finde ich die Formulierung, die Schlägerei des alten Mannes. Das klingt fast so, als hätte der alte Mann jetzt irgendwie die anderen verdroschen. Aber wenn ich richtig informiert bin, waren ja eigentlich beide Fälle. Mitnichten war die eigentliche Fahndung auf Basis dieser Videoüberwachung erfolgreich. Das war halt einfach Fahndung. Das Einzige, was die Videoüberwachung gebracht hat, und das natürlich auch ein entscheidender Punkt dabei war, Bilder für die Medien, die man die ganze Zeit zeigen kann. Was hat man da gesehen? Jemand gesehen, der da auf dem Bahnhof einen Koffer in der Hand hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt wirklich das entscheidende Element war, was sie da zum Fahndungserfolg gebracht hat.
Ja, das ist nicht gesagt. Das ist, glaube ich, auch nie so richtig nachgewiesen, was da jetzt eigentlich der Fahndungserfolg war.
Ja, genau, das ist auch nie erklärt worden, weil ich meine, okay, klar, man sieht, da kommt jetzt so ein Mann hoch und hat einen Koffer. So, das, ich meine, gut, wenn man jetzt den Marktplatz in Hintertupfingen morgens um fünf gefilmt hat, ja, und da kommt ein Mann, steigt aus dem Auto mit dem Koffer und 20 Minuten später explodiert alles. Meinetwegen. Aber auf den Bahnhof kommt ein Mann, eine Rolltreppe hoch mit dem Koffer in der Hand. Ich meine, wie viele Tausende Bilder müssten sie an der Stelle haben? Wollen die uns ernsthaft erzählen, dass sie sich jeden Einzelnen angeschaut haben, festgestellt haben, wer das war, auch noch in dieser Bildqualität, die man dann gesehen hat?
Also schwierig. Und auch bei der U-Bahn-Geschichte. Ich meine, die Bilder waren ja nur ständig in der Tagesschau und sonst wo. Also ich kann mir kaum vorstellen, dass jemand die nicht gesehen hat. Aber viel zu erkennen war auch nicht. Ein Gesicht zu erkennen, mit dem man hinter jemanden identifizieren kann.
Gut, ich meine, das ist natürlich schon eine Versprechung des technischen Fortschritts. Mit dem wir Schritt halten müssen. Heute ist es vielleicht nicht so, aber das kann kein Argument sein, weil wir wissen auch alle, zumindest wir, die Technik gut genug kennen und beobachtet haben, über die letzten 20, 30 Jahre, selbstverständlich wird das kommen. Wir werden hochauflösende Kameras haben, die Hunderte von Bildern pro Sekunde schießen, die also einfach auch Dinge wahrnehmen können, die unser Auge nicht wahrnehmen kann.
Aber das wollen wir vielleicht gar nicht. Wir wollen nicht so beobachtet werden.
Ich meinte nur so auf dein Argument hin, die Bilder waren ja so schlecht, das geht ja gar nicht. Es gibt ja auch Leute, häufig so eine Argumentation, eure Videoüberwachung ist ja gar nicht gut genug, um so was zu machen. Das ist eine ganz gefährliche Argumentation.
Das war auch nicht die Argumentation. Die Argumentation ging ja nur darum, es wird hier so getan, als hätten wir dieser Videoüberwachung bestimmte Dinge zu verdanken, die wir da nicht zu verdanken haben.
Am krassesten finde ich eigentlich das Statement. Und jetzt finden das alle normal. Also einfach eine Feststellung, von der ich einfach mal nicht glaube, dass es auch nur irgendeinen Beleg dafür gibt, dass das alle normal finden. Die Wahrheit ist, die Leute wissen nicht, dass sie überwacht werden. Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt jeden Platz betritt und das Gefühl hat, ich fühle mich gut. Es ist alles so normal, weil ich die ganze Zeit beim Popeln gefilmt werde. Ich würde mir jetzt eher einen dicken Strang aus der Nase rausziehen und keiner hätte es gesehen. Aber für sie ist das einfach klar. Alle finden das total normal, dass sie überwacht werden, wegen der CDU. Dann werden wir auch noch ganz andere Sachen machen. Dann werden wir unsere Kinder in den Knast schmeißen. Das ist total hilfreich. Wenn man 16-Jährige lange einsperrt, dann lernen sie endlich richtige Schwerverbrecher kennen. Und nicht nur die bösen Jungs von ihrer Schule. Dann werden sie sexuell misshandelt. Vielleicht auch noch von den Wertern. Wenn sie dann rauskommen, dann sind sie die besten Bürger, die man sich vorstellen kann. Weil sie einfach mal durch wachsende Sozialisierung... Das Schlimmste ist, der Start muss wert sein. Es kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass etwas technisch machbar ist, und der Start darf das nicht tun. Also das ist eigentlich der Grund, warum man sie eigentlich sofort von ihrem Posten entfernen müsste, finde ich. Weil das geht ja nun gar nicht. Das steht ja wohl nicht im Grundgesetz, dass alles, was technisch machbar ist, getan werden muss. Da würde mir so einiges einfallen, was technisch machbar ist.
Das sollte nicht sein. Und wie gesagt, Gewaltenteilung hatten wir ja vorhin schon. Das scheint da auch keine Rolle zu spielen, sondern man macht eben.
Und was hieß du da jetzt so sprachlich? Ist sie eine gute Rednerin? Ich habe nicht den Eindruck.
Ja, das ist von der Rhetorik schon Hausbacken. Obwohl natürlich rhetorische Mittel darin strecken. Also wie gesagt, diese Reihung, Verbrecher, Täter, Terroristen, sogar mit so einer Steigerung drin. Also das macht sie schon. Das ist natürlich auch rhetorisch geschickt. Am Anfang auch gleich diese, das nennt man Captatio Benevolentiae. Wenn man also das Wohlwollen der Zuhörer erwecken will, dann sieht sie, da sitzen viele alte Leute. Dann sagt sie eben, die Eltern unter uns werden sich erinnern. Und so, man, das ist dann auch nochmal, die werden dann gleich mit einbezogen. Also da ist schon eine gewisse Rhetorik drin.
Das ist vielleicht... Da waren doch wahrscheinlich nur Ältere.
Jaja, wahrscheinlich, genau. Es hat flüte Sieg dazu animiert. Also das ist schon rhetorisch geschickt. Allerdings letztlich dann doch irgendwie hausbacken. Denn das sind genau diese Punkte, dass man eben sich in Dreierreihungen macht. Das hat ja auch der Ziercke vorhin getan. Also mit einer Basisschulung in Rhetorik kommt, glaube ich, genau das da raus.
Titelthesentemperamente. Der Start muss wehrhaft sein.
Ja, das war dann sozusagen der Schlussakkord. Da hat sie so eine Phase gebracht.
Da muss auch jeder Ja sagen. Oh ja, natürlich, weil wenn der Staat nicht wehrhaft ist, dann ist er schutzlos dem internationalen Terrorismus, Nazis, Kinderporno, Wirtschaftskriminellen und Raubkopierern ausgeliefert. Das kann ja wohl nicht sein.
Nein, das kann nicht sein. Deshalb stimmt man gleich zu und applaudiert, dass der Staat wehrhaft sein muss. Das ist eben das Problem. Wie gesagt, bürgerliche Freiheiten stehen da nicht auf der Tagesordnung. Das scheint nicht so das Thema zu sein. Jedenfalls nicht bei dem Publikum.
Haben wir denn noch was mit Sicherheit eigentlich in unserer Liste? Das ist ja auch ein tolles Ding.
Wir haben noch Herrn Bosbach und Herrn Schäuble.
Wen nehmen wir denn da zuerst?
Den Schäuble müssen wir zum Schluss nehmen, weil das doch noch mal eine ganz besondere Qualität hat. Dann würde ich doch jetzt erstmal den Bosbach nehmen.
Was begleitet der Bosbach noch gleich für ein Amt?
Der ist Fraktionsvorsitzender der CDU.
Fraktionsvorsitzender der CDU. Ein sehr dankbarer Job, oder? Bosbach, Wolfgang. Stellvertretender Vorsitzender ist er. Was man nicht im Hirn hat, muss man im Browser haben. Und so sieht es ja auch aus. Also fragen wir mal Herrn Bosbach, was sein Kommentar zur Zeit ist.
Online-Durchsuchung geht nicht mit Messer und Gabel und geht auch nicht mit dem Fernglas. Dafür brauchen wir den Einsatz modernster IT-Technik. Und da kann eine Mail dafür ein Beispiel sein.
Das ist ja ganz spitzfindig.
E-Mail. Die fahren auch wirklich auf, was geht, oder?
Die fahren auf, was geht. Na ja, das ist in dem Zusammenhang natürlich gesagt worden, als es darum ging, dass E-Mails von Behörden den Bundestrojaner enthalten.
Ach, war das der Kommentar?
Genau, da musste er sich irgendwie äußern.
Ach, wie dumm.
Sein Argument, wieder das Ablenkungsmanöver, modernster IT, das war ihm natürlich wahrscheinlich ganz klar, dass E-Mails nicht zur modernsten IT gehören.
Aber das war doch nun wirklich ein, wie sagt man so schön, das hat zurückgefeuert, oder? Also ich meine, zu implizieren, dass jetzt alle Behörden irgendwie ihre E-Mailsysteme dafür verwenden, Shard-Software zu installieren, overwired. Und dann kommen sie als nächstes mit, bitte mal die Steuererklärung online machen.
Ja, klar, natürlich. Das ist schon genau der Punkt meiner Steuererklärung. Das ist klar. Ja, und wie gesagt, er hat das dann irgendwie so auf den Punkt gebracht, mit diesen seltsamen Metaphern, also mit solchen Bildern, dass er sagt, also den Fernglas ausspähen.
Messer und Gabel. Ich frage mich, machen Sie die normalen Durchsuchungen mit Messer und Gabel und Fernglas? Also wenn das jetzt für eine Online-Durchsuchung nicht reicht, dann...
Da, wo es noch keine Videoüberwachung gibt, macht man halt mit dem Fernglas. Guckt mal, wie die Leute sich auf den Platz aufhalten. Da schon. Aber Messer und Gabel, das kann ich mir wirklich nicht gut frauen.
Das sieht bestimmt lustig aus. Was ich in dem Zusammenhang noch, das kam ja schon häufiger, aber was hier auch noch so drin war, es gibt so ein ganz böses Wort in der ganzen Diskussion. Und das ist modern. Das haben wir auch bei den Wahlcomputern immer wieder. Offensichtlich sind Politiker auch beseelt davon. Und ich frage mich, wie lange es eigentlich noch sein kann, dass dieses Wort so positiv besetzt ist. Also das modern, was heißt das denn? Was ist jetzt mal so sprachlich? Jahrhundert ist das schon... Wann kam denn das moderne auf?
Das moderne kommt im 19. Jahrhundert auf. Also das Wort, dann ist auch nicht so ganz klar, was damit gemeint ist, weil es mit der modernen losgeht.
Das Wort gibt es auch erst seit dem 19.
Modern im Französischen, das ist ja zunächst mal im Französischen entstanden, damit ist ja das gemeint, was wir als Neuzeit bezeichnen. Also es geht sozusagen mit der Moderne in dem französischen Sinne bei Luther irgendwo los. Vielleicht sogar noch früher.
Dabei hieß es schon immer das, bedeutet es schon immer das, was wir jetzt so im Kopf haben?
Es ist im 19. Jahrhundert auch wieder in Frankreich und dann wahrscheinlich von da aus in Großbritannien und Deutschland gekommen. Es bezeichnete da insbesondere solche Dinge, wie den technischen Fortschritt, das bezog sich ganz deutlich auf die industrielle Revolution. Modern, das waren eben so Konzepte, Stahlbrücken, der Eiffelturm und so. Das ist das...
Ja, aber ich meine, das Wort selbst, gab es das auch schon vor den Stahlbrücken? Also gab es da auch schon Dinge, die modern waren? War mal die Postkutsche modern oder ist das Wort selbst erst dort entstanden?
Jahrhundert in Gebrauch gekommen. Man müsste mal jetzt genau nachgucken, wann es entstanden ist. Das kann ich so ohne Weiteres jetzt auch nicht sagen. Müsste man gleich mal nachfragen.
Wie entstehen denn solche Worte? Also ich meine, ist das dann wahrscheinlich eine Neuschöpfung, die dann aus irgendwas zusammengeklatscht wurde und dann hat man eben diesen Stempel... Und das ist jetzt so Zukunftsverkörperung? Hat man das so gemacht? Oder gab es das schon immer und früher hat es einfach Klopöbel bedeutet und...
Ja, es gibt natürlich beides. Es gibt einmal die Möglichkeit, dass das Wörter neu, mit neuer Semantik, also mit neuen Bedeutungen, mit neuen Bedeutungen versehen werden. Das ist auch sehr, sehr häufig. Also alte Wörter, die plötzlich was Neues bedeuten. Wir hatten das ja vorhin schon mit Al-Kaida, was eigentlich erst mal da... Siehst du, da war dann ein Datenbank und irgendwann eben die Terravereinigung. Und dann gibt es natürlich andere Wörter, die tatsächlich neu gebildet werden, zu einer bestimmten Zeit. So, schauen wir mal.
Also die allwissende Müllhalde stellt vor allem die Moderne so dem der Tradition entgegen, was ich aber interessant finde, dass man die, ausgerechnet die Konservativen, die sich ja immer so traditionsbehaftet finden, immer so die Ersten sind, die bereit sind, irgendwas über Bord zu schmeißen. Während dann die böse Sozialdemokratie strukturkonservativ ist. Das ist alles vollkommen absurd.
Ja, hier sehen wir es schon. Grimmsches Wörterbuch, das ist überhaupt das, was man immer nur empfehlen kann. Sollen wir mal suchen. Grimmsches Wörterbuch.
Wir werden einen Link in die Sendung schreiben.
Ja, von Jakob und Willem Grimm, die man in Deutschland eigentlich nur so kennt als Märchenerzähler.
Die haben auch ein Wörterbuch gemacht.
Die haben aber vor allen Dingen das erste richtige Großwörterbuch der deutschen Sprache initiiert. Das hat dann ewig gedauert, bis es fertig war. Das ist erst im 20. Jahrhundert, Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts, fertig geworden. Über ein Jahrhundert hat man daran gearbeitet, glaube ich, ungefähr. Das ist natürlich schon ein Jahrhundertwerk. Es liest sich manchmal ein bisschen komisch, zum Beispiel, weil der Goethe immer mit Ö geschrieben ist, sondern nicht mit OE, wie man es eben seinerzeit gemacht hat. Da liest man unter Modern, Attraktiv und Adverb, nach heutiger Weise betont, modern, also nicht modern, sondern modern. Aus dem französischen Modern, das auf das spätlatanische Modernus zurückgeht. Aber spätlaten heißt natürlich, dass es eine Neuschöpfung ist, die eben nicht schon im latanischen da war. Erst im 18. Jahrhundert übernommen, wo es Nering noch in französischer Schreibung Moderne mit E hinten mit der Erklärung Neu, neulich, nach der jetzigen Mode, Façon, Tracht, Manier, Artweise oder Gewohnheit anführt. Später ganz eingebürgert. Modernar oder moderne Art, also Kunst, moderner Geschmack, die moderne Kunst, Wissenschaft und ähnliches. Moderne Sprachen, im Gegensatz zu den alten, moderne Bildung, im Gegensatz zu der auf der Antike beruhenden moderne Weltanscheidung gegenüber der mittelalterlichen oder gläubig christlichen. Mit den Mitteln der modernen Technik erarbeiten, mit moderner Plastik erhielt ich die vollständige Sammlung der Medaillance, welche Graf Tolstein Messing geschnitten hatte. Das ist ein Zitat vom Bild.
Habe ich da gerade Mode gehört? Mode und moderne hängen zusammen. Das heißt, wenn die Leute davon reden, dass wir was modernes haben wollen, dann sagen sie eigentlich modisch.
Ja, kann man vielleicht so sagen.
Wir hätten gerne jetzt so einen modischen Trojaner.
Ja, der Mode entspricht, der jetzigen Mode entspricht.
Ja, das klingt doch schon sehr viel zutreffender. Mich also gerade auch in dieser Wahlcomputer-Debatte, eins unserer Lieblingsthemen, da zeigt sich das auch ganz deutlich. Also Leute glauben, dass sie jetzt dadurch, dass sie Computer verwenden, also es sei einfach modern, Mode halt, es ist jetzt einfach Mode. Jeder hat jetzt gelernt in den letzten zehn Jahren, ach so, naja, so ich ziehe eine neue Wohnung, was brauche ich, brauche Strom, Wasser, Gas oder was auch immer, so zum Kochen oder Heizen. Ja gut, also ich brauche was zum Heizen, ich brauche was zum Waschen, ich brauche was zum Pinkeln und ich brauche einen Internetanschluss. Und ich brauche einen Computer, weil, denn wenn ich keinen Computer habe, dann kann ich ja noch nicht mal schreiben oder lesen oder keine Ahnung. Die Leute haben glaube ich das Gefühl, dass sie ohne Computer gar nichts mehr tun könnten. Auf jeden Fall haben sie gelernt, dass man bestimmte Dinge jetzt so macht, man schickt so Mail zum Beispiel. Das ist ganz modern, nicht? Das hat Herr Bosbach auch schon erkannt. Mail ist total modern. Aber was er eigentlich meint, ist, es ist total in Mode gekommen. Und weil das jetzt so in Mode ist, müssen wir das auch machen.
Und weil Computer gerade in Mode sind, brauchen wir auch den Wahlcomputer.
Genau, weil sonst sind wir ja unmodisch und dann sehen wir aus, wie Ostdeutsche nach der Mauer öffnen.
Der CCC hat sich immer dafür ausgesprochen, dass wir das Computer nennen, Wahlcomputer, und nicht Wahlmaschine, weil es ja tatsächlich ein Computer ist. Das war unsere PR-Attacke. Die Hersteller haben das ja immer verharmlosen wollen mit dem Terminus Wahlmaschine. Da sieht man wie so...
Oder Wahlgerät.
Wahlgerät.
Ist aber nicht gerade gelungen, weil hinten steht ja auf den Ledermaschinen tatsächlich Wahlcomputer drauf.
Genau. Aber auf der anderen Seite, so gut finde ich das gar nicht mit dem Wahlcomputer, weil eben Wahlcomputer eben auch modern klingt. Jeder will einen Computer haben. Meine Mutter will einen Computer haben. Neulich bin ich im Zug gefahren mit meinem Laptop. Da hat mich eine alte Frau, die neben mir ansaß, neben mir saß, mich angesprochen und hat mich auf den Computer angesprochen. Sie wollte auch so einen Computer. Dann hat sie dauernd auf mich eingeredet, erzählt, dass sie ja jetzt 80 Jahre alt sei und so. Aber sie will jetzt auch einen Computer haben, weil man das jetzt haben will. Und dann will man auch Wahlcomputer haben. Also wahrscheinlich in einem nicht informierten Gemeinderat, wenn da einer sagt, wir müssen jetzt mal was tun, die Gemeinde muss modernisiert werden, wir brauchen Wahlcomputer, schreien doch alle hurra und wollen einen Wahlcomputer.
Klar, aber im zweiten Schritt kannst du natürlich auch ganz andere Sachen damit transportieren. Und die sind meiner Meinung nach wichtig, dass nämlich die Computer machen Probleme. Computer tun nicht immer das, weil das Problem mit Wahl, Maschine, eine Maschine weiß, ist etwas, das tut halt etwas. Und genau nur das. Und das ist auch nicht in der Lage, irgendwas anderes zu tun. Ich weiß das. Das muss ja auch mal gesagt werden. Mein Gott, am Ende hört uns hier noch jemand zu.
Nein, ich will nur sagen, es gibt eben verschiedene Ebenen. Auf der Ebene der Semantik, der reinen Bedeutung hat natürlich der Chaos Computer Club sehr recht, um klar zu machen, dass es damit eben Probleme gibt, dass die verschiedenen Sachen programmierbar und manipulierbar sind. Es ist besser, von Wahlcomputer zu sprechen. Auf der Ebene der Konnotation, also der Gefühle, die man noch mitempfindet, wenn man das Wort hört, ist natürlich Wahlcomputer auch gefährlich, weil Wahlcomputer modern klingt und so klingt, wie etwas, was man haben will.
Hm, vielleicht sollte man... Also ich verstehe, was du meinst. Ich verstehe, was Sie sagen wollen, Sie haben recht. Wie sagte man früher zu Computern? Elektronenhirn. Das fand ich auch super scharf.
Elektronenhirn.
Das war so auch... Da war so dieses Menschelnde auch noch so mit drin. Intelligenz. Das ist ja komplett weg. Also ein Walelektronenhirn.
Wahlrechner.
Ob sich die Leute da schon wieder... Ob ihnen da zu viel entzogen wird in der Diskussion. Wir kommen ab.
Mit Computern keine negativen Termini. Computern sind so innen. Außer natürlich...
Das wird sich noch ändern. Sie sind noch innen. Aber irgendwann sind sie auch so normal, dass sie eigentlich nur noch an dem gemessen werden. Also noch hat es für manche immer noch was Neues. Wir leben auch noch in einer Zeit, wo ein Großteil unserer Gesellschaft nach wie vor Computer überhaupt erst entdeckt. Überhaupt erst begreift, was man damit tun kann in positiver und negativer Hinsicht. Teilweise ist sie überrascht, was sie in Böses widerfahren kann. Teilweise sind sie überrascht, was sie damit auch Kreatives tun können. Wir sind noch nicht da, dass es so ist wie Autofahren. Ich meine, du kannst heute im Mercedes fahren und dann sitzt du dich danach in einem Citroen. Die Sitze sind ein bisschen anders. Aber die Pedale sind an der gleichen Stelle. Man hat da auch so einen Standard gefunden, das ist bei Computern sogar noch ganz weit von entfernt.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber das Problem bleibt, dass man da wirklich mit der Sprache an die Grenzen stößt.
Ich wollte ja auch nur auf diesen Begriff moderne, den er ja auch gebracht hat, hinweisen, dass der halt auch in der Diskussion immer wieder so eine Variable ist, mit dem man irgendwas schön färbt.
Ja, genau, das passiert.
Wir sind uns einig.
Das ist positiv konnotiert. Und jetzt nochmal das Wort Konnotation zu nennen. Das können wir ja verlinken in der Wikipedia. Konnotation.
Kannst du auch mal erklären, was ist denn die Konnotation? Also das, was man eben einem Begriff zuschreibt, würde ich sagen.
Ja, was über die Bedeutung hinausgeht. Also die Wörter haben auch noch oft so einen emotionalen Nebengehalt, der über die Bedeutung hinausgeht. Also Computer wird als positiv empfunden. Modern wird als positiv empfunden. Ja, und internationaler Terrorismus ist eben negativ besetzt. Die Täter sind negativ besetzt. Deshalb bringt Merkel das noch an der Stelle.
Die Metaebene.
Das ist nicht eine Metaebene, sondern das ist etwas, was zu der Bedeutung noch mit hinzukommt. Das ist noch keine Metaebene. Metaebene werden wir darüber sprechen und das problematisieren. Dann sind wir auf der Metaebene.
So, kommen wir zum Endspurt, würde ich sagen.
Ja, wir haben ja noch das Sahne-Stückchen. Das muss man sich wirklich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Dann machen wir das mal. Herr Schäuble, was haben Sie denn dazu zu sagen?
In der Online-Durchsuchung wird Verschiedenes verstanden. Das ist wahr. Da wird sowohl verstanden der Telekommunikation, der Verkehr als auch die Durchsuchung in den System selbst, weil die technische Entwicklung eben so ist. Aber da müssen wir jetzt dann schon fast die Internet-Experten genauer befragen. Nicht so entwickelt, dass eben unsere oder meine leihenhafte Vorstellung, dass das Internet so was Ähnliches sei wie eine moderne Telefonanlage, das stimmt eben lange nicht mehr. Und deswegen braucht man da, wenn sie wollen, kann der Herr Fromm das auch genauer erläutern, der versteht es. Ein wenig richtig verstehen wird, tut er es wahrscheinlich auch nicht, denn das wäre gar nicht gut, wenn der Präsident des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz ein Online-Experte wäre. Das hat er auch seine Fachleute.
Also es ist natürlich auch wieder von der Argumentation her eine Scheinargumentation. Das nennt man Argumentum ad ignorantiam. Also wir wissen nicht, also ist es gut. Also das wird ja richtiggehend inszeniert. Nicht nur, dass er darüber spricht, dass er keine Ahnung hat, sondern er verhaspelt sich ja auch so. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass das geschau spielert ist, denn so gut ist es nicht. Aber es wird also wirklich klar gelegt. Also wir wissen da alle nicht, aber es gibt Experten, die wissen das. Und denen müssen wir das mal schon überlassen.
Das ist bemerkenswert. Also er kokettiert geradezu mit seinem Unwissen.
Genau.
Und ich glaube, er meint dabei auch an eine Öffentlichkeit zu sprechen, die dieses Kokettieren irgendwie nachvollzieht, weil es ihr eigentlich auch so geht.
Also so dieses Internet, na ja, das ist halt so was wie eine moderne Telefonanlage. Da hat man da irgendwie so einen großen Klotz und da sind ganz viele Kabel dran und an der anderen Seite ist irgendwie der Mensch. Und so sieht es wahrscheinlich jeder.
Ja, aber er sagt eben hier, die Ermittlungsbehörden, die haben Experten, die kennen sich damit aus.
Die haben gesagt, das passt nicht mehr so ganz mit der Telefonanlage.
Ja, und denen müssen wir das jetzt mal auch überlassen. Die machen das schon richtig.
Aber eigentlich wissen sie auch nicht, wovon sie reden.
Na, der Chef weiß es nicht.
Der Chef, das wäre ja auch noch schöner, wenn der Chef wüsste, was Sache ist. Und das lässt er irgendwie so ein bisschen offen. Warum eigentlich? Er sagt im Prinzip, es wäre unangemessen, dass Führungspersönlichkeiten Kompetenz regeln.
Ja, das sagt er eigentlich, das stimmt. Das ist eigentlich erschreckend.
Ob er sich da selbst mit einschließt?
Ja, weiß es nicht.
Das kann nicht gut sein.
Das kann nicht gut sein. Also er ist, ja ja, das kann nicht gut sein.
Weil dann ist man am Ende so ein Nerd oder so. So ein total verkopfter Typ, der irgendwie gar nicht mehr aus dem Keller rauskommt und keinen Blick für das Große und Ganze hat.
Genau, und er hat den Blick für das Große und Ganze, weil er eben frei ist von diesem technischen Detailwissen. Aber es gibt die Experten und die sagen, passt schon und dann ist es gut. Also es ist eben genau die Argumentation gegen die demokratische Kontrolle. Das, was wir vorher schon hatten mit der Aufhebung der Gewaltenteilung, es soll hier nicht kontrolliert werden. Die Experten werden das richten.
Das ist mein zweites Lieblingswort in der ganzen Diskussion.
Experten.
Das ist also, was man auch nicht nur bei den Politikern findet, sondern auch in den Medien. Soll ich mal eine Tagesschau, was weiß ich, irgendwas passiert. Flugzeugunglück in Brasilien, irgendwie alles brennt. Schwurz, man schnippt mit dem Finger, kommt eine Experte. Computervorstellungen und so. Und man hat ja auch wirklich das Problem, man muss ja irgendwie glauben. Also es ist ja dann so dieses, ah ja, okay, alles klar, das ist jetzt wohl ein Experte. Und die Medien werden das schon wissen. Aber kennst du den Effekt, kommt dann mal ein Thema, wo man sich auch selber auskennt und man schlägt eigentlich regelmäßig die Hände über den Kopf zusammen. Das ist wirklich schlimm. Und das wäre hier wahrscheinlich nicht sehr viel anders. Ich meine, die haben sich auch wirklich furchtbar. Das ist jetzt echt die Frage. Also da gab es ja auch diese ganze Diskussion. Wir machen ja diese Sendung jetzt hier nicht wegen der Online-Durchsuchung. Aber jetzt haben wir nun wirklich auch diesen Fall. Ich würde nicht sagen, die Sache ist abgeschlossen. Aber zumindest ist ja der Dämpfer, der jetzt vom Bundesverfassungsgericht ausgesprochen wurde, so immens, dass man sagen kann, ihre ganze Argumentation ist irgendwie zusammengebrochen. Es sei denn, man geht davon aus, dass sie eigentlich von Anfang an niemals wirklich das gewollt haben, also diese universelle Anwendbarkeit, sondern dass es eigentlich nur so ein Scheingefecht ist, dass sie gesagt haben, wir müssen uns jetzt ausdehnen in alle möglichen Bereiche. Also sie streuen erstmal die absolute Maximalforderung rein, werfen alles drauf, was es gibt. Kinderpornografie, internationaler Terrorismus, Raubkopierer hatten wir jetzt in unseren Zitaten nicht drin, aber wir wissen, auch das ist regelmäßig zu Gast. Und viele andere, wie sagte Herr Ziercke, so schön Sozialschädlinge und sonstige Bösewichte, Wirtschaftskriminelle, also ganz schlimm. Innenminister haben sie noch vergessen. Und die wollen uns jetzt irgendwie alles böse, wollen uns nackt ausziehen im Internet oder auch nicht. Und jetzt müssen wir da was gegen tun. Aber die Strategie könnte natürlich auch sein, ach naja, okay, jetzt haben wir also hier das Themenfeld Internet. Wir haben eigentlich hier so recht keine Ahnung, aber wir müssen da jetzt irgendwie mal ran. Also werfen wir jetzt mal die Maximal-Forderung der Maximal-Forderung auf den Tisch. Dann warten wir, bis das Bundesverfassungsgericht sich darüber die Köpfe zerbricht. Und dann lesen wir am Ende die Brosamen auf und gucken mal, was man dann damit machen kann.
Ja, das könnte tatsächlich so eine Strategie sein.
Ja, deswegen sind sie auch glücklich über die Klarstellung. Ja, schön. Dann müssen wir jetzt selber nicht nachdenken.
Ja, so sollte das aber nicht sein. Nein, so sollte das nicht sein.
Aber es macht den Eindruck, als ob das so ist.
Was wollen die Bürger? Die Bürger wollen schon gewisse Freiheiten haben. Dann fragt man sich, warum dann Leute gewählt werden, die eigentlich einen starken Staat wollen. Das ist ja der gemeinsame Nenner.
Die Politiker sagen immer, die Leute wollen ja Sicherheit haben. Und sie hätten ja ein Recht, ein Anrecht auf Sicherheit. Ich habe dann mal als Grundgesetz geschaut. Das Wort Sicherheit kommt an einer einzigen Stelle vor. Und zwar in einem konkreten Zusammenhang. Da geht es um den Schutz vor Seuchen. Ansonsten nicht. Dafür steht da, weiß ich nicht, zehnmal oder zwanzigmal Freiheit. Freiheit, Freiheit, Freiheit, Freiheit, Freiheit. Freiheit, Freiheit, Freiheit. Haben wir glaube ich auch in unserer Hymne irgendwie Einigkeit, Recht und Freiheit. Also Einigkeit, Recht und Sicherheit habe ich bisher noch nicht gehört. Das schließt aber auch keiner auf, das Schloss. Jetzt haben wir viel darüber geredet, was die Neusprechfraktion von sich gibt. Was kann man denn jetzt machen? Wie kann man denn diese tumme Argumentation effektiv ausheben? Oder was sind auch die Fehler, die man nicht machen darf?
Ich denke, man sollte nicht den Fehler machen, sich da auch auf diese Scheinargumente einzulassen. Also dass man sich vom Ablenkungsmanöver hinreißen lässt und dann eben auch nicht mehr über die Online-Durchsuchung, also über die Durchsuchung von Festplatten spricht, sondern dann plötzlich in der Diskussion angekommen ist, wie schlimm das Internet ist. Klar gibt es da viele schlimme Inhalte. Auf diese Diskussion sollte man sich wirklich dann auch nicht hinablassen. Also da sollte man eben nicht mitspielen.
Ich glaube, jeder Zeitungs-Kiosk bietet einfach mehr Frivolität und Wahnsinn als das, was man im Internet so an einem Tag durchsurfen kann. Na ja, vielleicht nicht unbedingt rotten.com.
Ja, aber gut, es wird zum Teil auch fetischiert, was da im Internet so ist. Also rotten.com wird da eben auch als ganz böses hingestellt. Oder als Stream oder so.
Ach so, klickt es nicht an, wenn ihr es nicht kennt. We mean it. Wir haben euch das nicht empfohlen. Es kommt auch nicht in die Linkliste.
Kein Fall. Das sollte man auch nicht, ohne vorbereitet zu sein. Also wie gesagt, man sollte sich auf diese Ebene vielleicht gar nicht einlassen.
Du sollst es nicht anklicken, habe ich gesagt.
Weil diese Ebene eben wirklich dazu nicht passt. Sondern man sollte wirklich über das diskutieren, dass es geht, also hier einbringen in die Privatsphäre. Und man sollte eben tatsächlich auch eintreten für die bürgerlichen Freiheiten. Die machen schon Sinn. Und das ist eigentlich das, was auch in der Politik eine gewisse Rolle spielen sollte. Und nicht immer nur der starke Staat. Und es ist wirklich überraschend, dass gerade jetzt da immer nur der starke Staat eine Rolle spielt. Das ist vielleicht auch modern, weil wir gerade das Wort modern hatten.
Es ist Mode.
Ja, aufgrund der Anschläge, die wir ja auch täglich im Fernsehen sehen, irgendwo in der Welt, Gewalt und so, dann fühlen sich natürlich alle irgendwie bedroht und sagen, da muss jetzt mal was getan werden. Obwohl das natürlich genau das ist, was eben auch die Terroristen wollen.
Vielleicht sollte man einfach auch andere Ideen und andere Modelle entgegensetzen. Was wäre denn zum Beispiel davon, von einer starken Gesellschaft zu sprechen?
Ja, eine starke Gesellschaft.
Weil letzten Endes ist es ja auch so, ein Staat kann vieles nicht verhindern, aber eine Gesellschaft kann eine Menge verhindern. Eine Gesellschaft mit einem starken sozialen Zusammenhalt ist in der Lage, eine Schule befriedet zu halten. Aber ein Staat, der irgendwie in Panik Sicherheitskräfte engagiert und Polizisten vor Tassenzimmer stellt, wird nur an den Symptomen rum.
Gut, also das mit dem starken Zusammenhalt der Gesellschaft, das ist auch noch mal zu hinterfragen.
Na ja, der fehlt natürlich, klar. Aber das ist ja auch verbunden mit diesem, naja, der Staat muss da ja auch was tun. Ja, aber auf die Idee selber was zukommen, wird wenig appelliert.
Genau, also man sollte nicht immer nach dem starken Staat rufen. Also man kann viele Dinge auch selbst in die Hand nehmen.
Deswegen meine ich, also einfach so als Gegenbild, das auch zu skizzieren und zu sagen, wir brauchen eine starke Gesellschaft, wir brauchen eine große ehrenamtliche Beteiligung zum Beispiel, wir brauchen Leute, die sich irgendwie um diese Sachen, und wir schätzen das auch wert. Also es wird ja immer so Soldaten, Polizisten und so weiter. Das sind alles so die guten Feuerwehrmänner und so weiter, die uns irgendwie alle retten und bewachen und beschützen und irgendwie die anderen erschießen.
Genau, wir brauchen natürlich eben auch Bildung und Kultur, aber das muss nicht der Staat alleine machen, sondern da brauchen wir eben auch die Vielfalt. Deshalb, das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, warum ich denke, dass Wikipedia so ein wichtiger Ansatz ist. Da kann man nun sagen, was man will, und sagen, da gibt es auch viel Schlechtes und so. Aber es ist eben tatsächlich auch nochmal so eine Bewegung von Leuten, die was machen wollen und die sich da zusammenfinden. Und das ist eigentlich, glaube ich, auch ganz gut.
Könnte man sich noch eine Welt vorstellen ohne Wikipedia? Ich meine, wenn es das jetzt nicht gäbe, dann müsste man sofort damit anfangen, oder?
Ja, natürlich. Also gerade so, ich meine, wir reden ja hier von einer westlichen, freien Welt. Anderswo, da ist natürlich Wikipedia nicht gewollt. Da sollte es natürlich auch so etwas geben. Also solche Aktionen, das muss jetzt auch nicht unbedingt Wikipedia sein, aber dass eben Leute sich zusammenfinden und was machen. Gerade im Hinblick auf Bildung, Kultur, Kunst, Wissenschaft, das sind alles so Dinge, die auch ein wichtiges Gegenmittel gegen den starken Staat und auch gegen die sprachlich argumentative Verschleierung und gegen Neusprech und so sind.
Neusprech im Schnüffelschland, du willst auch einen Vortrag daraus machen, oder?
Richtig, da soll es demnächst einen Vortrag geben in Dresden, beim Gas Computer Club Dresden am 18. April.
Also nicht bei den Datenspuren, die dann glaube ich im Mai auch wieder geplant sind, sondern vorher noch?
Vorher noch, genau. Die machen wie die meisten Erfahrungsaustauschkreise des Gas Computer Clubs ja auch ein Programm, was dann auch die Öffentlichkeit ansprechen soll.
Aber man kann auch noch mal auf die Datenspuren hinweisen, die dann im Mai, ich habe das jetzt ja angeboten, noch nicht gesehen, aber ich weiß, das wird vorbereitet und das ist immer eine sehr nette Veranstaltung, kostenlose Teilnahme, gesellschaftliche Themen.
Genau. Und da hatte man mich eben eingeladen, ich sollte damals wachen, warum gerade in Dresden, und das gibt wahrscheinlich auch einen ganz guten Grund, denn in Dresden hat Neusprech schon vor Orwell eine Rolle gespielt. 1946 ist das Buch eines Sprachwissenschaftlers dort erschienen, Victor Klemberer. Er hat einen Buch veröffentlicht mit dem Titel LTI oder mit dem schwerfälligen, lateinischen Titel Linguaterci Imperii über die Sprache des Dritten Reichs. Und da macht er eben auch Sprachkritik und setzt sich also da eben auch mit Wortschöpfungen und nicht nur Wortschöpfungen, da geht es auch um so Fragen, wie wird Sprache verwendet, wie werden auch Konnotationen verwendet, eben in der Propagandasprache. Ja, und wie gesagt, also das...
Die Nazis waren ja auch nicht gerade arm an neuen Wortschöpfungen. Gestapo war es nicht anders.
Ja, sicher, also totalitäre Staaten, die natürlich auch irgendwie was, ja, also die Propaganda betreiben wollen, ich meine, Propaganda ist ja ähnlich wie Werbung. Die brauchen natürlich dann auch entsprechende positiv besetzte Begriffe. Und klar, das ist genau...
Okay.
Ja, und das, wie gesagt, ist in Dresden herausgekommen und von daher passt...
Passt, das ist wunderbar. Gibt es da schon einen Termin für den Vortrag?
Ja, wie gesagt, 18. April. Was hast du schon gesagt? Uhrzeit und Ort, da müsste man jetzt selber schnell im Internet recherchieren, beziehungsweise wir verlinken das natürlich alles.
Selbstverständlich. Kompletter Service bei Chaosradio Express.
Dann braucht man nur auf den Link zu klicken und weiß, wo und wann und das wird natürlich anders sein als mein Beitrag hier, weil man natürlich in so einem Vortrag eher mit Folien arbeiten kann, aber was Visuelles hat, dafür aber weniger so die O-Töne bringen kann. Das ist natürlich beim Podcast besser. Also es ist nicht einfach dasselbe nochmal, sondern natürlich komplementär.
Okay, wir haben es. Maha, vielen Dank. Auch vielen Dank wieder fürs Zuhören. Es wird fleißig Chaosradio Express gehört. Das lässt sich an unserer Serverlast ganz gut ablesen. Und wie immer muss ich erwähnen, wir sind an Feedback sehr interessiert, insbesondere an die dummen Jungs, die jetzt den bösen Link doch angeklickt haben. Schickt uns Feedback, chaosradio.ccc.de per E-Mail oder geht ins Blog, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de, wo es zu jeder Sendung einen Beitrag gibt. Da kann man schön Kommentare hinterlassen und auch mit den anderen diskutieren. Und wir freuen uns immer über Feedback.
Genau, das ist ja das Spannendste. Deshalb machen wir das ja.
Ja, genau. Ohne Feedback macht Podcasting überhaupt keinen Spaß. Habe ich auch schon mal gesagt. Aber das kann man auch nicht häufig genug sagen.
Genau.
Weil so ist das auch. Deswegen machen wir das hier alles. Wir wollen da ja auch ein bisschen in den Diskurs kommen. Ansonsten sieht es auch ganz gut aus. Chaosradio Express wird in der nächsten Zeit noch einen bunten Strauß an Themenvielfalt entfalten. So viel kann ich schon mal versprechen, aber ich werde nichts ankündigen, weil die Lehre zeigt. Kaum nennt man irgendetwas, dann fällt das auch gleich aus. Und jetzt haben wir aber genug geplappert und sagen einfach Tschüss und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.